et puis pour terminer ce journal je vous
propose de nous retrouver sous le soleil
du mois j'espère qu'il ya du soleil à
cannes georges bigot nous y attend et je
crois georges que vous nous faites une
petite surprise vous avez à côté de vous
l'une des femmes les plus belles du
monde nous la voyons en ce moment une
drôle de dame paraît-il que les français
connaissent bien puisqu'ils ont suivi ce
feuilleton avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
et farrah fawcett ce que nous voudrions
savoir oui c'est davantage de choses sur
votre personnalité
on sait que vous êtes texane quelles
sont les qualités essentielles des
texans et sont très amicaux est très
ouvert et vous avez fait quelques études
qu'il avait rien à voir avec le cinéma
j'ai été à l'université de texas et j'ai
fait une descente d'are alors alors j'ai
aucune équipe a étudié la de change
je crois qu'elle étudie l'architecturé
elle faisait aussi beaucoup du sport
beaucoup de terre sainte était
sculptures et j'aime beaucoup les sports
et les arts martiaux qu'on vous voit
pratiqué c'est à dire le judo le karaté
dans le feuilleton où les avez vous un
bruit ibis et harry et bien quand j'ai
travaillé il ya quelqu'un qui vous aide
à faire si vous pouvez par le faire il
ya quelqu'un pour vous doublez chez
c'est le mien tout seul un sondage
américain posées aux étudiantes a
récemment révélé que la quasi unanimité
étudiante lisais je voudrais être farrah
fawcett voilà leur idéal farrah fawcett
qu'en pensez vous est ce que vous prenez
ça très au sérieux
c'est pas bien j'étais très surprise
mais c'est très agréable quand vous
étiez vous étudiante quelles étaient vos
idoles
je vais penser aux audi a reçus car
j'étais un enfant j'allais pas au cinéma
très souvent mais quand je suis devenu
un intérêt pour les films j'aimais
beaucoup quinzaine et athènes malheur à
peu près comment êtes vous venu
finalement au cinéma
en tout cas très intéressant
une histoire hollywoodienne typique
j'allais à l'université du texas dans
les écoles américaines
il ya toujours les la plus belle
étudiante alors j'étais la plus belle
étudiants dans les journaux quelqu'un
d'hollywood ma fille ma photo et m'a dit
que je devrais venir voit les gouttes
les gens qui vous connaissent bien
disent que vous êtes très sensible à
l'humour et à une certaine folie
alors j'aime beaucoup d'humour content
car c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
c'est un conseil général l'humour et la
sexy je parlais de la folie parce que
hier soir il s'est passé un événement
vous vouliez aller au cinéma pathé est
alors racontez nous ce qui se passe et
comment ce que je peux expliquer ça
c'est un grand désastre
je n'ai pas pu monter les escaliers pour
aller au théâtre parce que les
photographes étaient tout auto et en
amérique on a des barrières pour
empêcher les des photographes
s'approcher trop près et quand je suis
sorti de la voiture tous les
photographes sont agglutinés autour de
moi et tout le monde pousse pousse et
les policiers les policiers de me
pousser
et en seulement me tirer les cheveux les
vêtements et j'ai eu très peur parce que
j'avais jamais eu cette expérience est
ce que vous rendez compte qui sait
peut-être pas passé sa canne depuis
brigitte bardot regarder en ce moment il
y à beaucoup de monde autour de la bulle
devant les caméras
eux c'est quand même un phénomène dont
vous êtes conscience vous en avez peur
ou tv c'est un grand compliment qu'on me
fait ce qu'on veut me voir j'ai jamais
tellement peur sofia soir c'était
tellement il y avait tellement de monde
c'était trop joseph jones gagnent oui
une dernière question qui va vous dire
que je ne sais pas si nous allons avoir
le temps dont on la réponse pour pouvoir
parler du film elle n'a pas de film à
cannes par à fossettes mail fait un
événement et ce film s'appelle quelqu'un
qui a tué son mari et nous allons la
voir apparaître dans l'extrait que nous
vous proposons qui fait une toute petite
minute dans un autre personnage celui
d'une femme qui a un enfant qui est une
femme comme tout le monde